The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: This lecture
tonight is our last chance
to pay attention to this process
I've been calling the Fred Ott
principal.
And forgive me for appearing
slightly repetitious
about this.
But to me, it's an
essential aspect
of our appreciation
of these early weeks,
to recognize that films like
The General, or Modern Times,
or the film we're going to
see next week, The Last Laugh,
Murnau's remarkable
silent film from Germany,
to recognize that these
astonishing, complex narratives
grew out of something
so primitive
and grew out of something
so primitive in such a
relatively short
time, is part of what
makes these early
films so interesting.
And the viewing you're
going to see tonight
is your last opportunity
to, in a concrete way,
experience something
of that process,
something of that
evolution for yourself.
Because the two Chaplain
shorts that you're
going to see, while they are, as
I indicated this afternoon, not
from the earliest stages
of Chaplin's work,
they're three or four
years advanced beyond that.
He's already mastered his
medium in certain ways.
And these shorts
are, in themselves,
very coherent and
interesting works.
And I hope you'll look at them
for their own intrinsic value.
But I also want
you to recognize,
as you think about those short
films, remarkable as they are,
how much richer, how
much more complex,
how much more demanding
and rewarding in many ways
Modern Times is.
And I think the same thing
could be said about all
of Chaplin's features.
There's an astonishing
distance between even the best
shorts or between most of the
best shorts and the features.
Some of the very
best shorts have
a kind of elegance
and purity, as well as
a level of comic
inventiveness that
makes them in their
own way almost
the equal of the features.
But, of course, even
the best of them
don't have quite the
reach or the resonance
of a film like Modern
Times or The Gold Rush.
One way we can perhaps clarify
some of what I've been saying,
and maybe also do
a bit more justice
to poor Buster Keaton, who
I think in many ways is
an equally remarkable artist
and in a technical sense
an even more interesting
director than Chaplain himself,
is to begin with a
comparison of the two.
Not so much because the
comparison will really
illuminate weaknesses
in one or the other,
but the contrast
between them I think
will help to clarify
what are some
of the essential qualities
in each of these director's
work in films.
And I hope that you'll
sort of think back
to the Keaton material
you saw last week as I'm
making these comparisons.
One way to think about the
differences between Chaplin
and Keaton, and also
to think about what
is essential about
both of them, is
to talk about the way they
deal with objects and the role
that objects have
in their films.
In Keaton's case, we might
say that the basic objects
of interest are usually
massive and gigantic things,
whole houses, locomotives,
as in The General,
an ocean liner as
in The Navigator.
And Keaton was interested
in intricate systems
and in the intricacy with
which these systems operated.
And he liked to pose
his Buster character
against these massive systems,
to see whether Buster could
survive them and to
show us certain aspects,
both of Buster's
resourcefulness and power
to muddle through, but
also his comic inadequacy
and comic failings as well.
And a number of the most
dramatic and famous bits
from The General could be said
to crystallize this principle.
Think of that magnificent joke.
It's more than a joke.
That cosmic joke, that
vision of experience,
that existential
mockery, but also
affectionate mockery
of human nature, that's
embedded in the cannon
sequence at the very beginning
of Keaton's most important film.
You remember how that works.
It's very funny at every level.
But as Keaton first
fails to fire the cannon,
then the second time
reloads the cannon
with 10 times as
much powder, then
gets stuck in
front of the cannon
and it looks as if
he's going to be shot.
But every move in
that sequence is
full of amusing comic business.
But think of how
as the joke builds,
as it keeps topping
itself, something else
begins to happen.
What begins to emerge,
as I suggested last time,
is almost a kind of vision
of life, a vision of life
in which human agency matters.
You do have to
struggle and do what
you can to try to save yourself
or accomplish your ends.
But then when your
ends are accomplished,
even when things work out almost
exactly as you had planned,
remember what happen.
The cannon does fire.
It doesn't shot at poor Buster,
who runs away from it and hides
in the cowcatcher of
the engine to avoid it.
But why doesn't it go?
Because at a certain
moment, the train
just happens to go around the
bend and geography and physics
collaborate with
the Keaton character
in order to create a shot
that actually does almost
hit the engine he's pursuing.
And it certainly
persuades the people
he's pursuing that
they are being
chased by more than one man.
And, in fact, remember
when the cannon fires
and we see that the outcome
that results is pretty
much the outcome that the
Buster character intended,
there's a double comedy
there, isn't there?
And it's a metaphysical
or an existential comedy.
Because what that joke is
saying is, of course, what
the whole film
also says and what
many other individual crescendo
jokes, we might call them,
also say in the film.
Which is that we get through
in life by muddling through,
by working hard, by engaging in
all kinds of sometimes almost
obsessive labor in order
to accomplish our ends.
But in the end, when we
do accomplish our ends,
it's not entirely because of us.
It's because of accident.
And when we don't
accomplish our ends,
it's also because of
accident often, as well as
because of our human frailty.
So there really is a kind
of complex understanding
of the world implicit
in the kinds of jokes
that Keaton manages to
tell us, as if there's
a sort of understanding
or interpretation
of life embedded in the
best moments of The General.
And this kind of
vision of experience
wouldn't really be
possible if Keaton
was as interested in individual
encounters with small objects
as Chaplain is.
Because the distinction
between Keaton and Chaplain
in terms of the way
they use objects
is that Chaplain is in love
not with large, gigantic
structures, but with tiny ones.
He wants to see how Charlie
manipulates his cane.
He wants to watch Charlie
interact with a hamburger
or with a shoe that he is
pretending is a turkey dinner,
in a fragment from
a late film of his
that I'm going to show you
I hope in a few moments.
So if objects in Keaton
are massive and systemic
in a certain way,
the objects that
are most characteristic
of Chaplin's world
are small and manageable.
And the interactions between
the Chaplain character
and these objects are often an
occasion for the exploration
of character.
When the Tramp character
encounters a particular object,
one of the things he is
characteristically tempted
to do is to transform its
use, is to make it useful
some other purpose.
As if in the contest between
Charlie and the world,
Charlie has some
transcendent power
to allow his
optimism to transform
a recalcitrant reality, to
make the reality kind of bend
to him.
And it becomes
especially poignant,
as you'll see in the passage
from The Gold Rush I'm going
to show you in a little while.
It becomes especially
poignant when
we understand how minimal are
the constellations that Charlie
finds.
When he transforms this
shoe into a turkey dinner,
he's actually starving.
And although it may
psychologically help him out,
we can see his resilience
facing hunger and making
the shoe do for a meal.
So what is expressed there is
something of the character's
imaginativeness,
but also something
of his resilience and optimism.
Because when he encounters
the world, his relation to it
is one of a magician
or a transformer.
He's always trying to impose
his imagination on the world.
And if you watch
Chaplin's films--
this is true of his shorts
as well as his longer films--
if you watch Chaplin's
interactions with objects
closely, you will
see a continual drama
in which the imaginative
world of the Tramp
is in some sense in
a kind of conflict,
or a kind of
collision, or at least
a kind of angry conversation
with the world in which
the objects of the world are,
although they may resist,
are constantly
under the pressure
of the transformative power
of Charlie's optimism,
resilience, and imagination.
So it's small objects
in Chaplain that matter.
And they declare for
character, rather than
for some cosmic
understanding of the world.
We can get at another
fundamental difference
and some of the strengths
and the alternate kinds
of strengths of both
Keaton and Chaplin
by talking about the different
protagonists or heroes that are
characteristic of their works.
In Chaplin's case, let's
start with Chaplain,
we often have heroes who have
grand visions, or schemes,
or hopes.
They tend to be
chivalric characters.
So sometimes the project they
take on is rescue the damsel,
protect the woman.
In the first feature-length film
or nearly feature-length film
that Chaplin made-- it
was a film called The Kid.
And it actually
involves a child.
The kid of the title is a
young boy, an urchin, very much
like the real Chaplain in
his childhood in London.
And the Tramp character,
who is himself starving,
encounters the kid and
has to protect him.
So it's actually a
story of maternal--
there's a maternal quality
to Charlie in this.
He's much more like a mother
than he's like a father.
But anyway, it's in a certain
sense a kind of sentimental
parenting fable, in which
we see starving, miserable,
down-at-the-heels Charley
defending a person who's even
more vulnerable and even weaker,
even less able to take care
of himself than Charlie is.
And although it is a deeply
sentimental film in many ways,
it also was a film that provides
another occasion in which we
can see the Tramp character's
imaginativenes operating.
Because as I suggested
this afternoon,
one way you can also see it
operating in chase sequences
because he makes such amazing
split second decisions
about how to elude his pursuers.
And often those decisions
reveal his intelligence
and his improvisatory quickness.
So almost everything that
happens in a Chaplain film
returns in some sense to our
sense of the Tramp's character.
And we feel that especially
strongly I think in The Kid
because one of the
things that happen--
I think The Kid is 1921.
And one of the things
that happens in The Kid
is that we see Charlie
exceeding himself
in imaginative
resourcefulness because he now
has to protect a child.
And what you feel is
that his compassion
and his protective instincts
mobilize a resourcefulness
and an intelligence that
you can't help but recognize
and you can't help but see.
And so that in a certain sense,
there's a grand scheme here,
protect a child, save a child's
life, or protect an orphan,
or protect a young
damsel in distress
from bandits and outlaws,
that sort of thing.
And then Chaplain himself,
the character himself,
often has grandiose visions
of wealth or of success.
Some of his films,
as in Modern Times,
include dream sequences or
fantasy sequences, very, very
clever, intelligent sequences.
Because you can tell
that they are taking
place in a subjective
realm, itself
a kind of thematic
and technical advance
in the making of movies.
That Chaplin found ways
to introduce images
that the audience would
recognize instantly
as taking place, not
in the real world,
but in the subjective life
of the characters as part
of his achievement as
much as a mature director.
So the Chaplain hero is
often an ambitious character,
although he often fails.
He has large ambitions.
He has chivalric tendencies.
He's hopeful, resilient, in many
ways grandiose and sentimental.
And the Keaton
character couldn't
be more opposite in some ways.
He has sometimes been called
wrongly the great stone face.
But he's a character who
sort of muddles through
without any grand schemes.
The Keaton character
usually isn't
trying to do anything more.
The largest thing
he ever tries to do
is impress a woman,
as he does in Cops.
Mostly what he's
just trying to do
is survive, get through the
day, get around the corner,
keep this ship from sinking,
keep this locomotive
on the track.
One might even say that
in The General, which
is his most grandiose plan
in all of Keaton's films,
what the Buster character does
in The General is the most
ambitious and remarkable.
He's going to
recapture his train.
He's chasing the
Union army as if he's
fighting the war on his own.
But it's important
to realize how
we're supposed to understand
that in a deeply comic way
because the Keaton character is
so wedded to his engine that's
really not thinking about
any more marshal victory
or winning the war.
What he wants to do
is recover his engine.
So even there, there's
a kind of smallness,
a kind of lack of ambition,
a lack of grandiosity
to what the Keaton
character is doing.
So he wants to
just survive and do
a task, again a
very sharp contrast.
The treatment of women,
a third category,
might be a way of seeing
them in sharp distinction
to each other.
Chaplin's treatment
of women is deeply
sentimental and chivalric.
They're almost always, with
the partial exception of Modern
Times-- and I'll talk
about that briefly
in a moment-- they're almost
always treated sentimentally
and as characters
who need protection,
who are weak and vulnerable,
as well as beautiful
and stand for some
kind of purity.
They are an inheritance or a
vestige of the Victorian ideal
of women.
They were put on
pedestals because they
were too pure for the world.
And they were also too weak
to open doors for themselves.
They had to have men
do that for them.
So Chaplain's female characters,
with the partial exception,
dramatically partial exception
of the gamin in the film you're
going to see tonight,
tend to be of this sort,
Victorian stereotypes.
And his treatment of them
is deeply sentimental.
If you think about the treatment
of the heroine in The General,
you'll see how dramatically
Keaton diverges from this view.
Remember, Keaton is not
making fun of women in that.
He's making fun of the
Victorian stereotype of women
that appears in so many movies.
So when the Keaton
character picks up
that woman when she's
hiding in the potato sack
and throws over his
shoulders, and throws her
onto the pile as if she's
another sack of potatoes,
or later in the film
when the Keaton heroin
begins to do such stupid
things that you begin
to realize that she is
one of the great airheads
in the history of movies.
Do you remember some of
the tricks she pulls?
Like she ties a willow
tree across the tracks.
She tries a rope
across the tracks
to stop the next train
from catching up with them.
Or she sweeps out-- do you
remember this business-- where
she sweeps out in the
cabin of the engine
while poor Buster is struggling
to keep the engine going?
She doesn't like a little
bit of soot on the floor.
Keaton makes fun of this figure.
But he's not making
fun of women.
He's not making fun of
actual living females.
He's making fun of the
stereotype of women
that appears not
only in the movies,
but also appears in sort of
the popular conception of what
women are.
In any case, we
can see how deeply
mocking and unsentimental
Keaton's treatment of women is.
One final contrast that I think
is helpful and interesting
might be the contrast
that we might
generate if we tried to
describe the visual style
of each director.
Chaplin favors close shots
and emphasizes character.
He aims for a totally
realistic style
in which you're oblivious
to the camera's presence.
You're not supposed to
think about the camera.
He wants to create a camera that
is as transparent as possible.
You're supposed to just
focus on the action.
Chaplain's idea is that his
camera is a window on reality.
And he doesn't want the
window or the window pane
to be part of your understanding
of what you're watching.
There's something social
and character-oriented
in Chaplin's visual
style and especially
in his preference for
closeups which reveal
the psychology of character.
The contrast with
Keaton is very dramatic.
Keaton is a more interesting
director in a technical sense.
He'll mix his shots
much more often.
He'll use closeups.
But he also loves long
shots and middle shots,
depending on the effect
he's looking for.
If you think about what a
master he is of the long shot,
think of the moment, for
example, in The General
where the camera
backs up far enough
so that we can see
Buster working furiously
on the car that carries
the wood, the wood
carrier on his train, working
furiously with his head down,
while we see the train move
across the battle line.
So that he ends up
in enemy territory
and he doesn't even know it.
So there's a kind
of cosmic joke.
And again, it's a joke that's
only possible in the movies.
I mean it's a joke that partly
depends upon the camera's
position, its power
to photograph motion,
and the fact that
it can encompass
a much larger
mise-en-scene that is ever
possible in a live theater.
So it's a technically
interesting achievement.
But it's also a morally
interesting achievement
because what does it dramatize?
The usual trick, the
usual thing we know
about the Buster character.
He's mostly oblivious to
the dangers around him.
And often the comedy in
Keaton comes from the fact
that he's oblivious
to his narrow escapes,
as we've said before.
So Keaton uses mixed shots.
He's much more interested
in creating an aura
of authenticity in his filming.
The General especially alludes
to documentary photography
made during the Civil War.
And some of the
images are actually
recreations of Matthew
Brady photographs,
very famous Matthew
Brady photographs.
It was very important
for Keaton to create
these realistic effects,
this sense of realism,
because so many of his
most magnificent jokes
depend on your recognition
that it's actually happening.
That he's not using
process shots.
Think of, for example, of
the unbelievable engineering
feat that was involved in the
final crash of the train, when
the bridge burns at
the end of The General.
Remember, there's no
digital animation then.
When Keaton did that, if
he didn't get on the camera
the first time, that was it.
And, in fact, it's
incredibly beautifully done,
It happens perfectly.
There's something
almost graceful
about that
catastrophic sequence.
It's so well done, in fact, it
even holds up today in an era
when we are so used to
special effects of a much more
dramatic and astonishing kind.
There are no special
effects in that sequence.
It depended on a
mastery of knowing
where to put the camera; a
kind of engineer's mastery
of various individuals
and machines
that were in motion at the
same time; perfect timing, so
that the bridge had
to actually burn down
at just the right moment for
the train to come over it.
There was no margin
for error there.
Again and again,
Keaton's comedy shows
us this level of
technical, as well as
intellectual or
thematic mastery.
Because, of course,
that moment when
the train crashes
into the canyon
isn't just a magnificent
visual moment
and a magnificently
comic thwarting
of the expectations
of the generals
who are running the thing.
But that moment
is also completely
consistent with the
mock heroic interests,
the mock heroic themes
of the movie as a whole.
And what I'd like to
do now is concretize
and embody the arguments
I've been making very briefly
and inadequately by having
you look at three scenes, one
from Keaton, two from Chaplain,
that can help ground what I've
been saying in particular
images, in particular moments.
The first scene is a scene that
I wanted to show you last week
and didn't have time.
I think of it in a certain
sense as a particularly clear
embodiment of what we might
call the Keaton vision.
And it's a sequence
that violates
one of Keaton's deepest
principles at the very end.
And I'm a little sorry it does.
And the sequence
is harmed by that.
There is a special effect in it.
And it's too bad that there is.
But it's one of the very
rare such moments in Keaton.
Keaton tried never to do that.
And as I mentioned to you,
sometimes very dangerous things
happen to Keaton.
And they happen in reality.
And he was often begged, when he
became a director of features,
to not do his own stunts.
But he always refused.
And he always did
his own stunts.
He broke his neck when he
was making The General.
And any continued filming
with a broken neck
for part of the time.
He didn't quite realize
how seriously he
was injured when that happened.
If you think back
to The General,
you might actually be
able to figure out--
it happens relatively early in
the film when he hurt himself.
When he's on the
hand car, when he's
chasing on the hand car and
he falls off the hand car.
And he actually did real harm
to himself in that sequence.
So this first sequence,
it comes from Cops.
And in many ways,
I think it embodies
that kind of aversion of the
trajectory or crescendo joke
I was talking about earlier.
It's a small version
of the cannon joke
that you see in--
or jokes plural,
because there's another
joke with the cannon
in the second half of the film--
that I've talked about earlier.
Let's show it, Greg.
And, of course, this is
the moment where Keaton
is in flight from the police.
The cops are chasing him.
He runs up this teeter-totter.
He runs up a ladder.
It turns out to
be like a seesaw.
And there we see
the Buster character
trying to elude cops who
come up on either side
of the teeter-totter.
You see his acrobatic qualities.
But part of what makes
it good is that we
know he's improvising here.
He's in trouble.
People on both ends
now are after him.
How can you escape this?
Teeter-totter up and down, it
seems as if there's no escape.
It's almost as if
every cop in the city
is now after poor
Buster, massive forces
arrayed against the lone
hero, a key to his comedy.
And, of course, that's
the process shot.
But it is a very
witty way to end.
I mean what does it depend on?
Among other things,
an engineer's
understanding of
the laws of motion.
Many of Keaton's
jokes depend on a kind
of collaboration with gravity
and call attention to that.
So it seems as if
there's no escape.
And he does not escape
because of anything that he
himself has really done.
It's contingent.
It's accidental.
But he does escape, right.
It's as if the universe
sometimes , not always,
conspires to help us.
If we try hard,
sometimes it'll help us.
Sometimes it won't.
We're mostly foolish
characters muddling through.
The jokes say that
again and again.
It's a vision of life.
Now, I want to contrast
this kind of joking
and this kind of style.
Again, for that effect
to work, the camera
had to be pretty far back.
It depended on your seeing
the seesaw going up and down.
It depended on your
seeing the cops
on either side of the ladder.
So in that sense, it's a
characteristic Keaton moment,
a characteristic Keaton passage.
I want to show you two passages
from feature films of Chaplin's
that I think are those
characteristic moments
of Chaplin.
And you'll see how they fit
into what I've already said.
First, a scene
from The Gold Rush.
And let me set it up for you.
One of the delightful
and important things
about the Tramp's character,
as I mentioned this afternoon,
is after a while-- Chaplain
made a total of 81 films.
The vast majority of
them were silent films.
After the first couple
of films that he made,
the Tramp character began to
elaborate itself and proceed
by a principle of accretion.
That's very important
for us to be aware of.
Because think of
what this means.
If the audience for
Modern Times had
seen 50 Chaplin shorts or most
of Chaplin's movies-- and this
would have been true.
In 1936, the vast majority
of the movie audience
would have lived
through the silent era
and certainly would have known
a great many Chaplin films.
So when they came
to see Modern Times,
they had in their memory
banks all these other stories
about the Tramp.
And, in fact, they didn't
have to wait for Modern
Times for this effect to occur.
As the Tramp begin to
generate a kind of reputation
and more and more people
came to watch him,
what began to happen was that
each subsequent adventure
of the Tramp got richer,
not because of anything
inherent in the
new adventure, but
because the previous adventures
lay behind it and were
part of the Tramp's
ongoing identity.
So as the audience became
more familiar with the Tramp
and as Chaplin's gifts
for dramatizing character
and for making
movies enlarged, so
did the resonance of
the Tramp as a figure.
And I should have
said this afternoon
because it's the deepest
explanation for why
the Tramp became a mythic
figure, why the Tramp became
such a memorable
and powerful icon.
And in this sequence,
you're going
to see one of the classic
instances of the Tramp's
resilient imaginativeness in the
face of difficulty and danger.
In The Gold Rush, the
identity that Charlie
takes on-- by the time he comes
to make his feature films,
there are dozens and dozens,
30, 40 short films in the past.
And all of those identities,
all of those adventures,
feed into and inform
the more recent ones.
When the audience then comes to
watch Modern Times and The Gold
Rush, it has that
history behind it.
In this particular
film, Charlie takes
on the identity of a '49er, not
a football player but a miner,
who's gone to Alaska for
the Alaska gold rush.
We've seen him as a waiter.
We've seen him as
a ship builder.
We've seen him as a
pawn broker's assistant.
We've seen him in a whole
range of other jobs.
And until Modern
Times, each film,
even the feature-length
films, only
show Charlie in one occupation.
It's only in Modern
Times where we see him
in multiple occupations.
It's one of the things that
marks Modern Time's greater
complexity from
the earlier film.
So what's happened,
he goes to Alaska.
He finds himself
stuck in a cabin
after a terrible
avalanche and snowstorm.
He's stuck in the
cabin without food,
with a massive,
gigantic fellow, one
of his favorite antagonists.
Mack Swain, there's a name.
And Chaplain certainly chose him
because he was so humongously
large that when he was
juxtaposed against Charlie,
he looked even more menacing.
Well, in the sequence
you're about to see
Charlie is confined in a
cabin, in a horrible snowstorm,
starving, with this
gigantic fellow, who's
beginning to look at Charlie as
if he might be a tasty morsel.
And it's Thanksgiving.
It's Thanksgiving.
They're about to have
Thanksgiving dinner.
What are they going to do?
Watch Charlie's
imaginative response.
OK, Greg.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Even before this, we've seen
the Mack Swain character
look at Charlie with
a kind of hungry eye.
And you'll see him
do it again here.
Watch how Charlie interacts
with particular objects,
with small objects.
What he's done is he's cooked
a boot, one of their shoes.
The shoelaces become spaghetti.
Did you see the
subtlety of that moment
where Charlie look frightened?
Watch the range of
emotions that he's
able to express in his face.
Now, you see how
he uses closeups,
how it's a drama of character.
You see now, he lacks
Charlie's imaginativeness.
So he doesn't survive as well.
It's almost like
mind over matter.
It's that quality in
the Chaplain character,
I think, more than
any other, that
explains why people loved him.
You see, if you act like
you're eating good food,
you almost are.
All right.
That's enough Greg.
You get the idea.
It's a remarkable film.
And you get an idea.
Now, the next sequence I want
to show you is in some sense
even more powerful.
It's less comic, although
there are comic elements in it.
It's Chaplain at
his most dramatic.
And it's the final sequence of
the film City Lights, the film
that precedes Modern Times.
Five years separate them.
But it's the last film he
made before Modern Times.
And it's essentially
an urban drama,
in which the Tramp
character finds himself
protecting a vulnerable woman.
And the woman he's protecting
is a blind flower girl.
She's blind.
And so she's even more
vulnerable and deserving
of protection than a sighted
flower girl would be.
So Charlie sort of takes
her under his wing.
And because she's
blind, she doesn't
realize-- there's
a kind of trick
in the beginning, a
visual trick, that
makes the blind
flower girl believe
that Charlie is a wealthy man.
And Charlie allows
her to believe this.
He's the Tramp.
But he allows her to
believe that he's wealthy.
And he visits with her.
And she has an aged
mother, something
like the character you
see in The Immigrant,
who dies in the
course of the film.
And the second
subplot in the film
has Charlie befriending
a very wealthy man, who
is incredibly nice to him when
he's drunk and kicks him out
of his life when he's sober.
And his irrationality is
part of Chaplin's critique
of capitalism, I think,
because he's a rich man.
But when he's drunk,
he loves Charlie.
And he gives Charlie
money and so forth.
But Charley uses this
to get a fortune.
And he sees an article in a
newspaper about a Swiss doctor
who can fix blindness.
And he sends the flower girl
to Switzerland or someplace.
And she has the operation.
She has her sight regained.
And the Tramp character has
had his usual misadventures.
And he's just
getting out of prison
at the very end of the film.
So the encounter
he's going to have
with the now sighted
flower girl, which
is the very climax of City
Lights-- this encounter
that he's going to have
with her is an encounter
in which he and the audience
know perfectly well who
all the characters are.
But she has never set
eyes on Charlie before.
And she has the idea that
her benefactor, the man who
sent her for the operation
and restored her sight,
is a wealthy and
handsome fellow.
Here is the ending
of City Lights.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So for the audience, this
moment has tremendous poignance
because the audience
is aware of things
that the female character
is not aware of it.
That there's her benefactor,
this shabby little tramp.
So her condescension
to him in this sequence
has tremendous poignance
for the audience.
And look at the closeup
on Charley here,
Charley sees who it is.
Charlie knows who it is.
The only thing that's wrong
with this ending is the titles
are unnecessary.
The faces are so eloquent,
they're unnecessary.
The words aren't needed.
In fact, the words
even simplify.
Can you see how
Charley's expression
involves pride, as well as
affection and a kind of love.
He's incredibly excited
and happy to see her
and to see her sighted.
See the power of a closeup.
She suddenly realizes
who it is from touch.
The least necessary intertitle
in the history of movies
is about to appear.
But look at the closeups here.
Look at the art
of these closeups.
Another unnecessarily line.
There are people who have
said that that last closeup is
the most eloquent closeup
in the history of movies.
It might be true.
Because the
complexity of emotion
that's playing across
Charlie's face there--
it's hard for people
who haven't seen
the whole film to
fully grasp it,
although I tried to set it up.
It's partly that he
knows there can never
be anything between them.
It's partly that he's
full of joy over the fact
that he's been able to help her.
But there's also a sense of
their inevitable separation,
of the differences between them.
And that's part of
what's reflected
in that closeup at the end.
And another thing I would
call your attention to,
part of Chaplin's
subtly, is look how
he doesn't hold it too long.
A truly sentimental
director would
have held his final
shot, Charley's face,
twice as long,
three times as long.
But do you notice how
wasn't there for very long?
His hand was over here and
then the screen goes blank.
He doesn't milk the moment,
even though it's an immensely
complicated moment.
But the most important thing
to say about this scene
is that it's a scene
that's played out
by the drama of the face.
It shows how Chaplin had reached
a point by the time he reached
his maturity in the
1920s, had reached
a point where he
could create films
in which closeups on
expressive actors' faces,
and especially closeups
on the Tramp's face,
could reveal worlds of meaning.
The range of contradictory
feelings and meanings
that run across the
theater of Charley's face
in these final
sequences of City Lights
are proof of the eloquence
of the silent film
and are a particularly
distinctive signature instance
of Chaplin's art.
Well, in the time
I have remaining,
what I'd like to do is talk
very quickly about Modern Times
itself, the great
masterpiece that you're
going to be seeing
in a few minutes,
as a way of sort of setting
up some of the things for you
to watch for.
But I feel badly
that I couldn't do
this fully enough with
The General, which
is an equally complex film.
And I only have a
few minutes here.
So I can hardly do full justice
to the astonishing richness
and complexity of Modern Times.
But I want to call
your attention
to certain features
in it and count
on your being as attentive
and generous in your viewing
as you possibly can.
I'm sure you'll pick up
other things as well.
First, the context of the film.
I've already mentioned this.
So I don't have to spend
a lot of time on it.
But it's very interesting and
significant that the film was
made in 1936, released in 1936,
something like seven or eight
years into the sound era.
There hadn't been any
silent films made.
Now, I'm not saying that
Modern Times is actually
a truly silent film.
It's not.
It has a soundtrack.
And the soundtrack
is complex and rich.
And I'll say at
least a word about it
before I'm finished here.
But in every
fundamental respect,
Modern Times wants its
viewers to think of it
as a silent film.
It invokes the
tradition of silent film
and especially the
tradition of Chaplin films,
to which it
systematically alludes
in virtually every frame.
So the context for
the film is first is
that it is in a certain
way a kind of silent film.
There is no synchronous
dialog in it.
There are sound
effects-- and, of course,
there's music-- a soundtrack
the Chaplain arranged
very complexly.
And it's a very rich soundtrack.
But there's no synchronous
dialogue until the very end.
At the very end, there
is synchronous dialogue.
And it's Charley who speaks it.
In fact, the film was advertised
as follows in many newspapers.
It was, "The Tramp speaks."
Well, watch for what happens
when the Tramp speaks.
It's one of the film's
great and serious jokes.
He does speak at the end.
And it's the only moment.
You do hear dialogue
elsewhere in the film.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
This is what I wanted
to say about sound.
But you don't see
synchronous dialogue.
You don't see people
moving their lips and words
coming out of there.
You see people on
a screen talking
or you hear people
on a radio talking.
But you don't see someone on
screen actually moving his lips
and words, sound coming
out, until the very end,
when Charlie does his song.
He sings a song.
He plays a waiter near
the end of the film.
And he sings a song.
And he tells a
story with the song.
Watch for what happens.
So the Tramp does talk.
But it's a wonderful comic joke.
Another aspect of the
context of Modern Times
is it takes place
during the Depression.
But the subject
matter of Modern Times
was Chaplin's typical
subject matter.
It was about the Depression.
It was about hunger,
about misery,
about someone who can't find a
job, about two homeless people,
about the conflict
between capital and labor,
about the irrationality
of both sides.
It was literally about
the turmoil and trouble
that was going on during
the Great Depression.
Many people predicted,
not only that the film
would fail because it was
really essentially a silent film
in an era when no one was
interested in silent film
anymore, but also that it would
fail because it was rubbing
the audience's noses
in the very experiences
they were trying
to escape when they
came to the movies, the
escapist theory of why
people attend films.
Of course, both
predictions were mistaken.
Modern Times was a significant
commercial success,
partly because Chaplin was
very clever in the way he
did his exhibition of the film.
He released it first,
not in mass release,
but to elite feeders,
which charged
quite a great deal of money,
and then slowly allowed
the film to reach larger
and larger theaters.
He anticipated certain
modern marketing methods
with the release
of Modern Times.
And, of course, by
1936, Charlie Chaplin
was an internationally famous
figure, of such stature.
He was about the only figure,
maybe apart from D.W. Griffith,
about whom people had begun
to write essays calling him
an artist.
So Chaplain occupied
a unique place.
And that was also part
of why Modern Times was
waited for so fully.
So the context of Modern
Times is important.
There's something brave and
surprising about the fact
that it was about the
miseries of the Depression
during the Depression, that it
was essentially a silent film
in the middle of the sound era.
Both very bold decisions
on Chaplin's part,
both characteristic of his
ambitiousness as an artist.
Like Keaton's The General, we
could certainly call this film
also a culminating text,
a summarizing text,
in several senses.
It's a culminating text in
terms of Chaplin's work.
And I've already
talked about that.
Every single person coming
to see Modern Times, who
had any experience
with the movies before,
would recognize in
Modern Times situations
and even physical spaces that
had occurred in earlier Chaplin
films.
So there was almost
a sense in which
Modern Times was a reprise of
the whole career of the Tramp.
And I mentioned
that Modern Times
shows us the Tramp for the first
time in multiple jobs Having
multiple sources of-- and, in
fact, multiple misadventures.
He goes to jail more
than once in the film.
We find him in a factory
more than once in the film
and so forth.
So there's a sense in which
the various separate episodes
of Modern Times, taken together,
dramatize, in small, the whole
of the Tramp's career.
And there are many specific
bits of business and scenes
in Modern Times that are
little repetitions, or echoes,
or reprises of earlier Chaplin
films, which have caused
a shock of recognition in
the audience, a happy kind
of recognition.
There are many examples of that.
There are many earlier films
which deal with restaurants.
You'll see some of
them from the shorts
that you've looked
at, certain echoes.
I won't talk about any of them
beyond mentioning that there's
a remarkable sequence in
the film-- if we have time,
I'll show it to you.
But we probably won't
have time-- in which
we see Charlie on skates.
And that scene alludes
to a whole short
that Chaplain had made, in
which he plays a waiter who
has to serve people on skates.
And you'll see that he
has to do that again
at the end of the film.
He sort of reprises that role.
And then there's
an earlier moment
in the film where we see
Chaplin states as well.
But the main point is that
virtually every moment
in Modern Times has some
counterpart in an earlier
Chaplain short.
So there would have been a sense
of the audience coming back
to Charlie, returning
to the world
that Charlie stood
for, when they
came to watch Modern Times.
So it's a culmination
of Chaplin's career.
But it's also in a deep
sense, like The General,
a culmination of silent film.
And it would have had
that nostalgic affect.
It would have had
that nostalgic effect
on the original audience.
Most of the original audience
would have recognized the film
as an embodiment of a phase of
movie going that had passed.
And we should watch it
in that way as well.
I want to say a word
about the Gamin.
That's the character, the
female character in the film
because she
represents an advance
over any previous Chaplin movie.
As I suggested earlier,
in most Chaplin films,
women are relatively
stereotyped and don't
play very active roles.
This is the first
film in which there's
a woman who seems to be in
some sense the Tramp's equal,
in many ways more
than his equal.
She has more energy.
She's a bit younger.
You might watch
for the ambiguity
in their relationship.
Is it a sexual relationship,
a romantic relation?
Probably not.
Charlie's a lot
older than the Gamin.
In real life, he was
having an affair with her,
I might mention to you.
In fact, he was famous
for having relations
with young women, especially
his young actresses.
And there were scandals
connected to Chaplin's name
partly because of this.
And Paulette
Goddard, the actress
who plays the
Gamin in this film,
entered on a career
of great fame
in the movies, partly
because of this role.
And you could see how expressive
and remarkable her face is.
This is the first
female character
who has energy, will, who has
a kind of aggressive capacity
to be resilient and
care for herself.
And that represents a tremendous
advance in Chaplin's work.
She's the first sort of
semi-independent female
in Chaplin's work.
And you can see
in a certain way,
she's a kind of
partner for Chaplin.
When this film ends with
Charlie and the Gamin
walking down the road
toward an unknown future,
the only difference between
that ending and the ending
we normally see in
a Chaplain short
is that Chaplain
is usually alone
when he walks down the
road toward the mountains
in the distance.
And in this film,
he is has partner.
So there's a slight
suggestion of,
if not exactly hopefulness,
at least the resilience,
of the capacity to survive.
You have someone to help you.
And you might watch the way the
Paulette Goddard character is
treated in the film.
Because she actually
represents something new
in Chaplin's work,
a real advance
in his understanding of how to
deal with female characters.
A new kind of respect for
women show up in this film.
I've mentioned the
soundtrack before.
But I want to quickly
call your attention
to two features of it.
One is that Chaplin arranged
the sound track very carefully.
And what you'll
notice if you pay
attention is that the
soundtrack has what
we might call a quality in
which particular themes recur
when certain characters
appear on screen.
And you begin to
associate certain melodies
with certain characters.
And you should watch
the way this unfolds.
I mean the melody that's played
behind the Chaplain character
was actually a popular
song of the day, entitled,
although the words are never
sung in the film, "Hallelujah,
I'm a Tramp."
And it was a song
about being free,
and not having to worry
about working, and riding
the rails, and so forth.
Hurray, I don't have a job.
Hurray I'm a free,
in those ways.
But each of the characters,
each of the major characters
in the film, has a musical theme
associated with him or her.
And you should watch the
way they sort of meld in
and blend together.
Chaplain took the sound in
the film very seriously.
I've mentioned
the talking theme.
Watch the mocking
way in which talk
itself, speech, is dealt
with in the soundtrack.
You might want to talk about
this in your recitations.
But ask yourself
what's going on there?
Why would Chaplain, in
the end, denigrate talk?
I think the answer is obvious.
The Tramp is a silent character.
It's as if this is the revenge
of silent film on talkies.
It's as if the film is saying
talk is crap, talk is silly,
talk is ridiculous.
Who needs talk?
Watch how the film repeatedly
makes fun of talking
or shows talking as
inadequate or unnecessary.
And also the way
the film associates
talkies with something
else that the film is
very hostile to, which is
mechanized industrialization.
The film is a critique
of the excesses
of capitalism and the
excesses especially,
the tedium of factory work.
And talk and talking
films are associated
with what the film identifies
as evil or dangerous,
as you'll see.
But there's also a
moment in the film
that-- I won't show it to you.
But I'll mention it and ask
you to watch for it-- where
we can see another way.
It's only one of the
ways in which Chaplin
manipulates sound.
And it's an interesting moment
because it's easy to miss,
easy not to register
what's happening there.
There's a moment in the
center of the film where
Charlie and the Gamin escape
their difficulties briefly.
Charlie gets a job as a night
watchman in a department store.
And the department store
is like capitalist heaven.
They've been living hand
to mouth, nearly starving.
And they find themselves
in the department store.
There's food.
There are beds.
There are beautiful
warm clothes.
There are toys.
There are even roller skates.
And there's a moment when
Charlie and the Gamin
exploring the store, having
this exciting experience
with all these goods,
which they are deprived of.
It's not an accident
that that scene is
at the very center of the film.
Almost all the scenes on either
side of the department store
scene rhyme with
each in certain ways,
as an aspect of the
structure of the film.
And I'll come to that in second.
I'll conclude with that point.
But the department store
scene is the only one that
doesn't have any counterpart.
It's right at the very
center of the film.
And what one can feel
is the way in which
that dramatizes the
injustice, the sense of haves
and have nots that is at the
center of the film's meaning.
The film is always in some
sense interested in that topic.
So there's a moment when
the Gamin and Charlie
find themselves in this store.
Charlie, in his exuberance
and high spirits,
straps on roller skates
and begins skating around.
And if you listen
to the soundtrack,
you'll see the soundtrack is
very beautiful and gentle.
And you know, dah.
It's very calming and exciting.
And as Charlie is
skating, the camera
shows that, in
fact, he's skating
in a very dangerous area.
The store is partly
under construction.
And on one point,
while he's skating,
he puts a blindfold on.
And he's still
skating very calmly,
and beautifully, and gracefully.
And the soundtrack under it is
very graceful and appropriate
to his feelings.
But what the camera
shows, what you see,
is him coming near
the edge of an abyss.
Actually, it's a platform.
He might fall three stories
down into the lower story.
And he's not aware of it
because he's blindfolded.
And the sound-- and
then, of course,
there's a certain moment where
he takes the blindfold off
and he sees that
he's about to fall.
And he gets nervous.
And he suddenly is no
longer so graceful.
It's kind of a minor joke.
But what's really
interesting about the moment
is to think about what Chaplain
is doing with the soundtrack.
Because when you reflect
on it, what you realize
is that what Chaplain has
done with that soundtrack
is have it reflect not
the external reality
that we're all watching, but
the inner feelings that Charlie
is feeling.
What he's done is
he's discovered
a way-- it's a simple point,
but it's a brilliant discovery.
He's discovered a way
to use the soundtrack
to express a subjective state.
And what he's also
discovered, of course,
is that-- although
other people had
discovered this principle too.
But Chaplin's using it
with great intelligence.
He's discovered that the
soundtrack and the visual track
don't have to
absolutely coincide.
That they can report
different emotions
or cause different
kinds of reaction.
And that what you get when
you have this disjunction
is something much more complex.
We see Charlie is
skating in danger.
But his obliviousness
to the danger
is partly registered by
the music, which tells us
not about what's
happening outwardly,
but what's happening
inside Charlie.
And there are other moments
like this in the film,
not necessarily
with the soundtrack,
but in other ways, in
which the subjective states
of the characters are explored.
Pay attention to
those because they're
very remarkable and interesting
moments, in which Chaplain
is expanding the
repertoire of film.
The structure of the film
is especially interesting.
And I won't say more
about it, than to say
if you watch closely
what you will see
is the structure is a profound
structure of repetition.
As in The General,
the film's first half
is revisited in the
film's second half.
It's as if the film is based
on a series of rhyming scenes.
In the first half
of the film, there's
a fantasy sequence in
which we see Charlie
and the Gamin inside a kind
of cabined environment,
inside a kind of domestic scene.
It's actually a
fantasy scene, in which
Charlie imagines a suburban
heaven for him and the Gamin.
In the second half
of the film, there's
an actual cabin in the mud
flats that they live in.
And those two scenes are
sort of in conversation
with each other.
There are two extended
sequences in factories
and involving the
malfunctioning of machinery.
And what you'll notice,
if you pay close attention
to the film, is that this
principle of rhyming scenes
creates a situation in which
in the second half of the film
you partly feel that
you're revisiting
scenes and experiences
that you've had before.
And one of the reasons
that this is a useful
and an important idea is that if
you think about Charlie's life
and you think about the previous
history of Chaplin's career
as a director and as an
actor, what you realize
is that in a deep sense
what Modern Times is doing
is replicating the history
of Charlie's career.
Because Charlie has
held a series of jobs.
Charlie has been in
15, or 20, or 40,
or a hundred different
environments.
And in virtually every
case or in every case,
the ending has been the same.
He has been released into an
ambiguous kind of homelessness
and freedom at the
end of the film.
There's something footloose,
homeless, and unfinished
about Charlie's life.
And after a while, you
come to realize you
this would have
been true by 1920,
if you had paid
attention to the 30
or so other Chaplin shorts
that already existed.
The fact is that it's
an endless process.
So another thing that the
structure of Modern Times
manages to dramatize, maybe
more deeply and powerfully
than any prior Chaplin film has
been able to do exactly because
of this mirror structure,
is that this principle
of repetition never
ends, that Charlie
is on a kind of treadmill.
And, of course, Charlie revisits
scenes and repeats actions
that we'd seen
earlier in the film
because his life is a
series of repetitions.
Because the film's
vision of social life
for a character like Charlie
is one that's so mordant.
What he's suggesting is things
are hard, things are tough.
This man's homelessness, this
man's hunger, will never abate.
He's going to have a
struggle for his whole life.
But we don't despair because
the Chaplain character
himself doesn't despair.
So pay attention to the way the
structure embodies the meaning.
The point I'm making
now, and I'll come back
to this later in the course,
the point I'm making now
is a way of talking
about what could
be called the film's
commitment to the principle
of organic form.
When the structure of a text is
organic, what is meant by that
is that the structure
itself embodies meaning.
That the way the
text is organized
carries the themes of the text.
And if you think about the
structure of Modern Times,
you'll see that it's a
marvelously distilled instance,
a marvelously clear instance, of
the principle of organic form.
What happens to
Charlie serially is
more meaningful in a
way than what happens
to him in a single episode.
And the fact that
we have this sense
that things are repeating,
that Charlie is on a treadmill,
that he lives a cyclical life,
that he'll always have moments
of hope and hopelessness, that
he'll have momentary times when
he finds a place to live
or find sufficient food.
But that it will
always be temporary.
That his life is
always on the road.
always in process.
And that, at the
same time, he never
lets himself completely despair.
There's always a moment where
his resilience reasserts
itself.
Where those elements
are embedded
in some sense in
the very structure,
the very organization
of the film.
And I urge you to watch it.
What's been embedded or implied
in a good deal of what I've
been saying tonight
also has to do
broadly with what might
be called as the director
Chaplin's complexity.
Almost every moment in
Chaplin, and certainly
almost every moment
in Modern Times,
has the kind of
multiplicity, or density,
or texture that I've
been describing to you
as the mark of a serious film.
The mark of what I want
to call a work of art.
And if you pay attention,
one of the things you'll find
is that even the moments that
seem on the surface to be
the simplest ones, are not.
Or even the
implications in the film
that seem the simplest are not.
Just one example, the film's
critique of capitalism,
of a certain kind of excessive
form of industrial capitalism,
is obvious and very deep.
I mean the film is deeply
hostile to the dehumanization
that work on the assembly
line generates for people.
And Chaplain works wonderfully
comic variations on this idea.
And yet if you think of
the film in a simple way,
if you think in the
film in a simple way
as a kind of Marxist
or left-wing screed,
you're really mistaken.
And some people did, in fact.
And Chaplain was hounded
out of the United States
later in his career,
in part because he
was associated with what we
thought to be left-wing causes.
But Chaplin's socialism was
of a particularly sentimental
variety.
And he was certainly no
systematic communist.
But the most important
thing about Chaplain
is his complexity.
Because if you look closely
at the film, one of things
you'll find that it isn't just
capital that's criticized.
It's also labor.
There's a wonderful moment in
the film when Charlie finally,
after times of difficulty,
reads in the newspaper
that the factory
is hiring again.
And he's very excited.
And he leaves the Gamin.
They'd been living in their
little sort of idyllic cabin
in the mud flats in the
second half of the film.
And he runs out to the factory.
And he gets hired.
And just as he's about
to start his work,
the workers go on strike and
his life is destroyed again.
And, in fact, the
truth of the matter
is that Chaplain is an
equal opportunity insulter.
He thinks that labor
is just as stupid.
Organized labor is just as
foolish, just as misguided
as capital.
Something of the complexity
of his social vision
is reflected there.
And something of the complexity
of his moral and psychological
vision is reflected in the
way the Tramp interacts
with the Gamin.
And in the way in which both the
Tramp and the Gamin together,
at different
moments in the film,
try to buck each other up.
So we see that there are moments
in which each character falls
into a kind of despair in
the face of the difficulties
that they encounter
and in which they
are helped by their partner.
So there's a kind of
complexity or maturity
in Chaplin's way
of understanding
even the social difficulty,
the social evils,
the social problems
that he recurrently
dramatizes in his film.
For those of you who have never
seen a Chaplin film before,
and especially those of you who
have never see Modern Times,
let me conclude by
saying I'm a little bit
jealous of the opportunity
you have to see
this film for the first time.
It's one of the very
few silent films
I think-- I think The General is
also one-- that actually stands
on its own.
That's worth watching,
even without any arguments
about its artifactual value.
I wish you the joy of
this remarkable film.